do you think
what that
being a woman in this space
you know throughout
the field of philanthropy we hear of
you know mr carnegie and mr rockefeller
and mr gates and mr buffett
has that played a role in how you
approach these questions
you know it's intere it's interesting i
almost feel
like a little bit
opposite on that like
there's something sort of soft touch
about the philanthropy space
you know
like something sort of feminine about
charity and giving in in a way that is
funny because the founders of all of
these foundations were men
but
i've often felt a little bit of a
pressure to like butch up my
conversation with like metrics and you
know we've got to be very measurable
around it instead of talking about you
know
you know children's faces and things
like that and so i i've almost felt a
little that it's that there's something
quite feminine about philanthropy in a
funny way because as you as you rightly
point out
most of the contributors financially to
the space have been men
um i don't know it might that might just
be the marketing around it you know that
we we're moving from
you know sally strothers you know with
with children in the street to
um you know muhammad yunus and economics
you know
well i think you're a wonderful addition
to this space and couldn't thank you
enough for sharing your insights how you
approach a philanthropy how you've
engaged with ian and your mom
uh all the things that we are grappling
with in this class the class by the way
is in a few weeks giving away a hundred
thousand dollars that's so cool and they
are empowered to make those decisions
and so it's wonderful to have your
perspective which is so highly relevant
to what they're doing
this has been a wonderful conversation
with liesel pritzker
she's shared so much with us and
inspired me and i can see from the faces
of our students inspire the students as
well she's passionately talked about
the challenge between the cold economic
metrics
and the smiles
it makes me wonder
what are you doing to make the world a
better place